one of the reasons that I love writing
about the arts
you know curating work is not even so
much so you're able to honor one
person's expression and and pay tribute
to that but because of how much it can
shift things in us you know Frederick
Douglass during the Civil War surprised
his audience when he spoke about this
idea you know his idea was that it
wouldn't be combat that would get
America to have a new vision of itself
but pictures right pictures he said and
the thought picture is that they create
in the mind or the way that we can kind
of slip in the back door of our rational
thought and see the world differently I
love that his speech was called pictures
and progress and then he retitled that
life pictures and as I came across the
speech I thought this is why I do what I
do do you know how many movements have
begun in the world when one person's
work one song one an impactful aesthetic
experience shifted things entirely for a
leader for a group of people you know
the environmental movement really
catalyzed and began when we saw that
Earth rise image you know taken from the
Apollo 8 and we saw that our world was
in an environment that we needed to
honor or think about the way that Brown
versus Board of Education would not have
had Charles black there that
constitutional lawyer if he hadn't seen
Louis Armstrong before him that night in
1931 in Austin Texas and in that moment
say to himself well there is genius
coming out of this man
and if there's genius in this black man
then segregation must be wrong and to
know in that moment that he was walking
towards justice as he put it when he
describes what got him to be on the
Brown versus Board of Education case you
know there's so many examples where
really aesthetic force more than a
rational argument alone has been what
has shifted and turned the tide you know
in the face of massive injustice so I
think of the arts as far more than just
a respite from life a kind of a luxury I
see it as a galvanic force really that
undergird some of our most impactful
changes and movements in this country
and in this world